après un 1er mai 2020 confiner les
syndicats réinvestissent les rues ce
samedi contrairement à l'année dernière
le défilé de la fête internationale des
travailleurs est autorisée la cgt la fsu
force ouvrière et solidaires appelle à
défendre les droits sociaux et la
liberté dans toute la france après un an
de crise sanitaire qui aura mis à rude
épreuve le mouvement syndicaliste
la période a été difficile car notre
action repose sur le contact la relation
il nous a fallu procéder différemment en
l'espace de quelques jours et nous avons
parfois eu un mal fou à le faire durant
un temps nous avons craint une forme de
distanciation syndicale avec la présence
des organisations syndicales étudiantes
et lycéennes et du mouvement gilet jaune
les revendications seront multiples dans
les cortèges précarité retrait de la
réforme de l'assurance chômage et de la
loa sécurité globale ou encore la fin de
l'état d'urgence
crise sanitaire oblige quelques
restrictions sont à noter pour cette
édition 2021
par exemple les manifestants devront se
munir d'une attestation de déplacement
dérogatoire de quoi amuser quelque peu
les organisateurs on a le droit d'avoir
des fanfares de jouer de la trompette de
parler dans la sono mais pas de passer
de musique amplifiée pour éviter de
provoquer des attroupements de jeunes
qui se mettent à danser
on chantera on voit depuis plusieurs
jours une mobilisation des militants
pour construire cette journée notamment
à paris en province on sait que dans
certains territoires certains ne
viendront pas à cause de la situation
sanitaire tendue selon la cgt c'est plus
de 298 manifestations qui se dérouleront
dans tout le pays notamment dans les
grandes villes comme nantes marseille ou
encore toulouse
de son côté la cfdt a choisi de faire
bande à part et de participer à cette
fête nationale des travailleurs sur
internet
laurent berger secrétaire général de la
cfdt donne rendez vous à ses internautes
pour un échange sur les réseaux sociaux